you ever driven that sump before I have
hello I'm Kyle Shepherd and this is
hidden Britain it's just like Jersey
courts as grantor except without all the
fast cars and exploding stuff in this
episode lap Bible have sent me to check
out Calvin Harris's hometown Dumfries
they take whichever 101 okay Part 1 I
want that one
oh wow
yes yes
this is good this is crackin good
mattress this is proper nice I thought
you said the budget was [ __ ]
yeah I love you turns out it wasn't just
the view but like an outdoor sent out to
offer it's also home to Europe's only
human slingshot another the lab Bible
challenge classic was expected to be so
big
you made that thing lately yeah came up
with the idea about 18 months ago I meet
Dave did the engineering and we built
ourselves and enough wiggle so so what's
gonna happen so I'm gonna get in the
harness when it driven back Animorph
yeah we press the button and off you go
naught to 60 in just over a second and
you'll be experiencing a sustained G
we're experiencing between 3 and 6 3
SEC's okay 360 awesome you've done it
yeah did it four times here doing
wouldn't do again this do you read you
read for all this yeah one of the
conditions is dyslexia and this my
harness are brilliant in you
here we emphasize a boost imagine if a
suicide gets a bit uncomfortable me old
Willy Wonka yes 60 miles per hour was
like half speed is that world which I
absolutely nailed so I thought this is
gonna be a piece of cake right let's do
it
during a struggle
trying to process what just
I wasn't feeling the best after the
swing shots to be honest so I thought
some musical therapy would help because
we're in Scotland I went to meet a local
bagpipe player
I'm dying to get my hands on that kind
of cook there myself yes there you go
I forgot to buy the kilt
my pipes are like way harder than me
look I wish I could have stayed and
jammed a bit more but to be honest it
was about time that I got on a level
with Clark's and May and the Hampstead
so I'm now a Galloway Tanksley at
Dumfries and I'm gonna be driving one of
these bad boys get a load of that how do
we get down the dribbler tank before so
what's the difference really in the car
15 tons big metal tracks and they need
to engine Wow okay but I'm gonna give
them a gonna get some fire anything from
Luke that's all I care
no you weren't going to fire it but you
get to drive it yeah awesome
okay big pulls ourself lots of mud yeah
weekend Boston well I guess there's
nothing else to do then
oh we go to drive attack
so you go oh feel like I'm in fury you
know that film rut pit
ah you see me I step with ah whoa it's
like I stand up we should send that like
we put all those I'm it's good I'm calm
I'm calm just I want to get back in
I'll never go down was it tons to going
you have a dribble attempt before I have
I was proper buzzed enough to drive in a
tongue unload Bible said they paid me
flaps and bears out at the town gets in
your head back to the cabins wash the
face paint off big day out big big big
big laughs now you knows it's working
that on the great side right listen
toothbrush no but I'm done preached
before what's it like is it good there's
like a few spoons and stuff Calvin
Harris is from Dumfries but the locals
say he's not the most famous person to
come from around there apparently that's
a poet called Robert Burns so to find
out more I went to the pub use to drink
in the globe in and had a chat with
Janie was a huge fun it was a poet
wasn't the best and Waylon was Velma and
Scottish point in the world so I've got
like a favorite poet of mine right
I read yourself as Louis you used to
call me on my cell phone late what known
you need my love call me on my cell
phone late night when you need my love
and I know when that hotline bling
that can only mean one thing see that
that writes what you think it up I think
that's more like a rigid core myself
Lucille really like to see that not sure
can I give you one apartment yes yes by
night by day a field a team the thoughts
of II my breasts inflamed and I I news
in sing thy name I only live to love me
well I think if anyone's listen to this
what one would deny like if you learned
something from Bernie I should work if
I'm going out for a night Island donkeys
I should learn a little bit learn a
little bit I can't go tryna learn some
work right okay Cheers
so some art burns Ches up lines in the
bag and some advice from cheeky Jane I
headed off to the famous Dumfries bar
and karaoke hotspot the hole in the wall
in
I'm have some awesome lads and lasses
and sang some absolute bounces the
drinks are flowing and the people of
Dumfries made me feel really welcome all
together a good night
the freezers been proper ace I've
discovered Robbie Burns and play the
bagpipes I also drove a tank an got shot
by a catapult
which may feel a bit sick to be honest
but all together it's a true hidden gem
of the British Isles until next time
you